pete was like babe let's go get some ice
cream at thrifty and i was like
oh my god
you are making me so
corny kim kardashian continues to gush
over her man pete davidson but this time
it's a small gesture that really gets
kim in the mood you are making me so
horny right aid thrifty it was literally
like one of the best nights of my life
after last week's cliffhanger fans were
waiting to find out what pete's sweet
surprise was when kim took her first
flight on her luck's private plane now
we know drugstore ice cream is kim's
interesting guilty pleasure
we have a special surprise for pete free
for the plate oh my gosh
oh
shut up these are my favorites
yeah the reality star has a serious
sweet tooth for ice cream and pete and
you know it's serious because kim
ditches her diet right before her sports
illustrated cover shoot i swear it's
like the cutest littlest thing i know
okay get over how sweet this was
but is it sweet or is it like being a
because i have a swimsuit shoot and i
shouldn't have eaten that recently kim
has been more comfortable talking about
her budding romance on the hulu show
including how she first fell for pete
and now if she's in love pete said i'm
gonna grow on you just just wait he's
like you're you're gonna
he knew are you in love um
i don't know if that's any of your
business
but it wasn't an easy adjustment for her
estranged husband kanye west
my life was never easy god sent me from
that crash
just so i could beat pete davis
the rapper's attacks on pete have been
anything but private with yay putting
the comedian on blast in his music and
instagram rants you just gotta roll with
it a source told et earlier this week
pete gets along very well with kim's
four kids which only makes her fall more
in love our source adds the reality tv
family played a big part in helping kim
navigate the situation as kanye made it
clear he didn't want anyone around his
kids that kim was with i just want a
drama-free
life
i never want the person that i'm dating
to be like subjected to public scrutiny
just because we're dating he knows what
he's getting himself into obviously but
i'm trying to minimize any tabloid drama
clearly the skim's founder is over the
drama and told et now she craves the
simple life he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Music]